[Applaudissements]
ce cri qui mode style autour de la table
si vous deviez partir un mois sur une
île déserte avec un des garçons ou une
femme à l'huile et bien sûr michel mr a
lui même
[Applaudissements]
l'invité de jean-michel même lui plaire
au patron hockey jean michel ça vous
fait quoi
bah je suis assez ému je suis troublé
mais j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient une
suite parce que ça c'est les paroles
après il faut que non là bas si
l'annoncé 10
je vois que vous regardez peu l'émission
parce que là vous avez mis le doigt dans
un truc non mais c'est ce que c'est une
fille à votre porte bien mais qui va
taper là vous êtes maintenant à d'état
moore usa des années sérieux ah oui je
suis marié ou pas bien sûr un très long
temps ça c'est si sa vraie caisse car
michel stop il dit c'est un peu le
stopper si ça ne se voit pas ce qu'il
respecte l'homme et qui respecte la
femme et respecte la
[Applaudissements]